welcome everyone
Jackson Institute I'm Ted Witten Steen
deputy director for leadership programs
and we really have an extraordinary
guest personal hero of mine someone who
has traveled from very far away to be
with us today at Yale from Manila in
maryam race' who I will introduce in
just a moment along with ambassador
Harry Thomas one of our senior fellows
here at the Jackson Institute and
someone who was instrumental in bringing
this extraordinary advocate for human
rights to the Yale campus and we welcome
her as a Jackson visiting fellow for the
talk today on journalism and human
rights fighting back against
disinformation I think many of you are
familiar with the Jackson Visiting
Fellows Program
these are distinguished practitioners
and Global Affairs who are invited to
spend an immersive multi-day program on
the Yale campus many of you have seen
and interacted with some of the Visiting
Fellows in this past semester including
former NATO commander Admiral Jim
stavridis former commander of US Central
Command General David Patraeus Maria
race' is not a soldier but make no
mistake she is a warrior fearless
tireless defender of democracy a
champion of transparency government
accountability freedom of speech and the
press both in the Philippines and around
the world and often in the face of great
personal risk she has been a journalist
in Asia for more than 30 years in 2012
she co-founded Rattler calm which is now
one of the leading news organizations in
the Philippines and prior to that served
as CNN's bureau chief in Manila and
Jakarta but that does not do justice to
what the work that she is doing in the
Philippines today and the way that that
resonates around the world when I was
sitting in coffee with Maria yesterday
she remarked how nice it was to be
sitting and looking out a window and not
fearing sniper fire okay so the work
that she is doing is very real and very
risky
in defense of world values and human
rights she travels with great security
in the Philippines she has to train her
staff on how to respond in the event of
surprise government arrest as many of
you know her reporting on a thority
authoritarian administration of
president rodrigo duterte has resulted
in repeated intimidation tactics and a
number of manufactured attempts to
detain her but she has fought back
against this disinformation and abuse of
power with great gusto and enthusiasm in
a way that has inspired so many others
she has said we are journalists and we
will not be intimidated we will shine
the light we will hold the line and it
is this courageous and deep early
inspirational vision that has resonated
worldwide that has earned her
recognition as Time magazine Person of
the Year in 2018 along with numerous
other accolades and we're delighted to
have ambassador Harry Thomas moderate
this conversation ambassador Thomas
served as ambassador to the Philippines
from 2010 to 2013 he witnessed Maria
raíces efforts firsthand he also served
as ambassador to Bangladesh and Zimbabwe
along with numerous other senior
positions in the US Foreign Service were
delighted to have ambassador Thomas as a
senior fellow at the Jackson Institute
at Yale
so Maria Reza has a brief presentation
highlighting some of the key work that
she's done in countering
authoritarianism and disinformation
after which she'll join the stage with
ambassador Thomas for a conversation
between the two of you and an
interactive Q&A with the audience so
please join me in thanking Maria race'
welcoming her from the Philippines to
New Haven to the Jackson Institute ntl
thank you very much
[Applause]
yay
I will run for about 15 to 18 minutes
and then kind of take you through oh
here are the three points so the three
points I hope to make in this one and
it's so good to see so many familiar
faces in the audience what's the problem
what's the problem and then why should
you care about the Philippines why are
we why is our dystopian present your
dystopian future and what are the
potential solutions the problem is very
simple it is the impact of technology as
an accelerant that has helped elect
authoritarian populist style leaders
that have used the technology to
actually make lies laced with anger and
hate spread faster than facts without
facts you can't have truth without truth
you can't have trust without any of
these democracy as we know it is dead
2020 is a critical year I think I hope
you guys do really well here because you
know what happens here will have a
global impact why why the Philippines
because this is the fourth year in a row
that the Philippines is the social media
capital we spend a hundred percent of
Filipinos on the internet hundred
percent are on Facebook Facebook is our
internet I interviewed Cambridge
analytic a whistle blower Chris Wylie
and I asked him you know what role did
the Philippines play he called it the
petri dish he said in countries like
ours because of the young population
hundred million people median ages 23
years old because of that they tested
these tactics of mass manipulation in
our countries and if it worked on us
they brought it to you they brought it
to the United States to Europe and so
petri dish is his word and he
said that they if it worked in the
countries like the Philippines and
Nigeria that they would then port the
tactics over the third part is I'm not
gonna leave you depressed because and
and also you need to be extremely
empowered because you're also a
frontline right some of my problems in
our country my personal problems the
attacks against me
come and happen on American social media
platforms part of what's changed the
entire information ecosystem is because
American social media platforms
allegedly have the same value some
democracy that we all have is they move
fast and they broke democracy so oh I
hope I'm wrong so what is it here's the
perfect example is that when I was in
2018 the Philippine government filed
eleven cases and investigations against
me I think that was why when time named
when I was one of four people four
covers that they had in 2018 when I saw
this I thought it was fake news and
forwarded it to our social media
platform so our the Artic team because I
was like oh they didn't tell me and then
as soon as I got a call telling me it
was CNN asking for a response
my stomach sank because I thought that
meant that oh my gosh we'll be attacked
again but you can't get attacked more
than we have although of course the
number of cases can go up in 2018
because of the cases that were filed
against us our revenue dropped almost
50% the end goal is to really bankrupt
us or it's a war of attrition
in 2019 my Valentine's Day gift from the
government is to be arrested and then to
be held overnight and then within five
weeks to be arrested again in order to
be here today I've posted bail five
sorry eight times I posted bail eight
times and I have paid more in
bail and bonds then Imelda Marcos who's
been convicted in four different
countries right my first the my lawyer
says that one of my cases the cyber
libel case it's a case where we
published a story in 2012 four months
before the law we allegedly violated was
enacted this case now began in August
2019 and we'll have a verdict on April
3rd
please keep track I could go to jail for
12 years on that one the guardians of
truth the guardians of truth and on the
four covers I was the only one at that
point who was both alive and free this
is what it takes to be a journalist
today that's crazy right here's the
problem and you know is so nice to MIT
to meet Tim Snyder and the whole way
here yesterday because I used this slide
almost in every time I speak I talked
about the problem like this if you can
make people believe lies are the facts
then you can control them Tim says it's
so much better and I recommend his book
on tyranny to everyone because it gave
me the political if we can contain the
pollution in our information ecosystem
maybe we're only looking at one or two
years of this dysfunctional democracy
but if we don't then we're looking at
decades and Tim actually lays out why
and how in on tyranny he said if you
want to rip the heart out of a democracy
you go after facts
that's what modern authoritarians do
step one you lie all the time step two
you say it's your opponents and the
journalists who lie step three everyone
looks around and says what's the truth
there is no truth right because if there
is no truth resistance is impossible in
the game is over what the civic
engagement look like in the age of
information warfare this time proves
power and information information is
power and now more than anything the
mullah report lays out Russian
disinformation and I wonder why we keep
letting in
the rain in our information ecosystem
here's what we went through in the
Philippines in 2017 we started to do a
report along with 12 other research
groups with a think tank it's we came
out with the phrase patriotic trolling
state-sponsored online hate and
harassment campaigns to silence and
intimidate they attack you pound you to
silence so they use freedom of speech
and expression to stifle a narrative
right if you're pounded to silence
that's the first step the second step is
they come and actually incite hate and
violence against you those are the two
tactics they flood the market with lies
instead of actually trying to censor you
flood the market with lies women are
attack in the Philippines at least ten
times more and these were the three
steps because a senator of ours Lila de
Lima she's a first term senator but a
former Justice Secretary she's the
former head of the Commission on Human
Rights she's been in prison for three
years now without any real trial and she
went through these steps as well the
first is an attack on credibility that I
mentioned it's her and me and our vice
president who's the head of the
opposition we were the three cases that
came through attack the credibility you
allege corruption you say it repeat it
exponentially a lie told a million times
becomes a fact use sexual violence
number two you know there was video of
her supposedly in a sexual act
it was doctored but congressman actually
threatened to play it at the House of
Representatives the minute you're
degraded as a sexual object it's very
hard to retain your credibility I think
I've been called every animal you can
think of every you develop a thick skin
but I'll show you some of it and then
the last part is before she was arrested
a few weeks before they they trended
hashtag arrest Lila de Lima and in my
case they tried to trend hashtag arrest
maria rasa in may
20:17 it didn't trend which is probably
why it took two years before they
arrested me
hey this is hashtag arrest maria rasa it
was in May 2017 we came out with the
story of the conversation between Trump
and Duterte and we weren't the only ones
the washington post it as well but this
is a content creator a blogger who now
works for the government but at that
point he was one of the produ tears and
bloggers he writes this hashed hashtag
arrest maria reza rapper just made the
philippines a legitimate target of north
korean nuclear missiles it's ridiculous
right and yet people think it's real
it's spread to hear twitter campaign
accounts this is a normal process they
take social media campaign accounts and
then pivot and weaponize it after taking
power that's what happened in the
philippines but that wouldn't answer
sanada call her to the senate hashtag
arrest maria Ressa then it jumps to a
real person i can smell an arrest and
possible closure of Rattler calm this is
may 2 years before the government tried
to close us down so you can kind of see
this astroturfing you seed the idea
first on social media bottom-up right
and then we go to the sexualized attacks
maybe maria restless dream is to become
the ultimate porn star in a gangbang
scene it's not but you know this is this
is this was on our Raptor Facebook page
with millions of followers and then this
me to the R P government makes sure
Maria Russell gets publicly raped to
death when martial law expands to lose
on it would bring joy in my heart these
are the nicer ones that I got guys his
school contacted me after I posted he
was a senior in college and his school
asked if I wanted to meet him I worried
the scorched earth policy what does it
do to our values right what does it do
to our young men and our women so here's
the timeline what we did is we began to
gather data we pulled the data all
publicly available and we took a look at
what was on rattlers page
and the way the pages of new scoops were
being used and we pulled out by Aaron
means corrupt in Tagalog and you can see
just like they did in the United States
right what they do is they look for a
fracture line of society
normally identity and then they pound it
until it splits wide open here it's
corruption there's a grain of truth
because endemic corruption that's norm
in the Philippines and yes some
journalists are corrupt but you can see
here from Jan 2015 to January 2016 which
is when the campaigns began here how
they began hitting it far more
repetitively and then here May 2016
that's when President Bashar Tet took
office and July when the drug war began
not coincidentally the attacks began
with the drug war our we had one
reporter in July of 2016 who was going
out every night and every night she
would come home with videos of at least
eight dead bodies only later would we
find that the average per night was
about 32 that's insane right so what we
did is we put a database together for
our social media team Rattler lives on
social media we drank the kool-aid we
really did build communities of action
with social media and helped Facebook
Twitter grow in the Philippines in this
one I did I'd mention where were
Facebook partners we're frenemies
Facebook and me we're we're one of two
Filipino fact-checking partners but with
that meant we also had API access here
right so in October of 2016
this one here these are the URLs that
spread the lies these are the Facebook
pages and profiles that spread these
URLs and then if it reposts more than
ten times it turns red in October 2016
we released our propaganda war series
that's the first time that we looked at
how Facebook algorithms impact democracy
we took 26 fake accounts and manual
counted how many other accounts they
could influence 26 could influence up to
3 million others right that's only 26
look at what happened in October of 2016
this is when the attacks began against
rattler online and then I want to show
you one account that attacked every
single new swoop pounded us and you can
see that this is a full-time job it's a
cut and paste right the same message in
page after page after page they're
posting them in the campaign pages of do
character you can see here sometimes the
reposting is 55 80 and the groups that
they posted in are the duterte and the
Marcus campaign pages this is a
full-time job so these are the kinds of
ways that you could get manipulated in
the Philippines it's not as much BOTS as
it is fake accounts and then now three
years later real people think about this
information like this here's the system
and a great quote by yuri andropov who's
the former head of the KGB and a former
head of the soviet union
he said this in format sia is like
taking drugs
the irony of drugs you take it once or
twice you're okay right you can you can
try cocaine and you'll be okay but if
you take it all the time you're forever
changed you become a drug addict right
you think differently you act
differently
now imagine that lies the information
warfare that we're living through is
coming in it's like a virus and we've
now caught it so we have to stop the
lies and we have to rehabilitate we have
to cure us we have to rehabilitate us
too in order to have democracy the way
it used to be our public sphere has been
thrown apart I'm going to show you what
an attack networks looks like against
the vice-president of the Philippines
she's a woman she's the head of the
opposition doesn't look like anything
like this but when you put it in a
network map that network is the same
network that attacks me that attacks
news groups that attacks any institution
that goes the questions the government
and it is so systematic that it is
broken down
by demographics this account creates
pseudo-intellectual accounts this
account this is the one that said
hashtag arrest maria reza creates
content for the middle class and this is
the anchor account for the mass space
she's a singer dancer kind of like a
more salacious spice girl and the attack
against Robredo began here right and was
amplified this is the same network that
attacks new scoops from there it jumps
to traditional media Manila times while
it sounds authoritative is the chairman
emeritus it's the head of international
public relations for president detective
and then from there it jumps to state
media and around that time they
announced that they were working with
China and Russia as well and then you
close that entire loop look at our
information ecosystem right you close
that loop by naming our singer dancer as
head of social media for the Philippine
government this is our yeah so she did
that for eight months and now has a
different job in government yes I know
welcome to my world historical
revisionism it's not done by say you
know starting here and then jumping
there you do it little step by step by
step and this is how do you turn Marcos
from someone kicked out of the country
to a hero and they did it by cut and
paste comments in facebook pages and the
comments look really normal it's just
meant to shift the way you think a
little bit dark part my parents even say
you can watch TV and news and roam
around the streets here I believe the
dark narration and full twisting of this
part of history during my elementary
high school days it wasn't all dark the
historians and maybe media made it all
dark
right makes you doubt it this happens a
lot and I have I will tweet you the
Marcos revisionism and it worked the
Marcoses are back 34 years after people
power this is natural language
processing and I just want to show you
how the threat of an arrest has played
between American news groups and
Filipino news groups so this was the
first time an arrest warrant was issued
the Department of Justice issued a press
release and something like 34 percent of
the stories came from the Philippines
and 27 percent from the United States
but what's more interesting is if you do
natural language processing and look at
the themes and when you look at the
themes you see the impact of fear you
see the impact of our own it's not
censorship it's just being smart the
story's done in the Philippines were
basically the press release of the
Department of Justice only Rattler asked
me for an interview and the story is
done outside the unite the United States
they talked about a detective rights
crackdown so those are the insidious
effects of fear and violence on on a
country this is what our information
ecosystem looks like on social media the
circles are the size is based on
eigenvector centrality the larger the
circle the more powerful the account but
this is very similar to what's happening
in the United States the Democratic
Party well this is our Liberal Party but
you know the the anti detective forces
are small and they're clustering
together but they're completely
surrounded by the pro detective Pro
Marcos communities who are far more
coordinated in controlling the narrative
on Facebook
the only time we won we as in like who
we call people looking for facts I guess
you know the narrative of my own arrest
for example I we won twice only twice in
three years the first time was when I
got arrested the second time when I got
actually arrested the second time was
when bono you two came to the
Philippines for the first time in 40
years and he praised he used ultraviolet
to honor the women so that was really
interesting here's what it looked like
in February last year when I got
arrested
and this is the first time you can see
the information ecosystem actually kind
of split in two but the methodology is
interesting because normal people people
who Duck who put their heads like
ostriches in the sand because it's too
complex it's too confusing too much
violence so they'd rather look away but
when I got arrested they actually
started tweeting or posting the news
groups but if you look at the pro
detective pro marcos clusters they
actively avoid tweeting traditional
media in fact they post stories they're
kind of trying to create their own
version of Alex Jones oh yeah that was
the salacious singer/dancer he's just
not as good as Alex Jones he was
ultimately taken down right so this look
at here they're looking for alternative
media sources here right that's that's
what we're seeing and it split pretty
evenly it's when if my my team member
said riah you should have stayed in jail
a night longer I'm like thanks guys this
I wish it's not it's not a good thing
how does it connect every country is
connected to a global nervous system of
disinformation networks in 2018 December
2018 this is the US Senate Intelligence
Committee released a ton of data it's
here and what we saw here is how this
American academic who's closely
affiliated with Artie and Sputnik that's
why they're there also writes for an
all-right Canadian website called Global
Research dossier but he also writes for
this IP this website that has an IP in
Russia and he is the most quoted expert
of this account
it's called daily sentry net this is
Rattler being attacked but this account
has since been taken down by Facebook it
was working directly with this the web
of interconnections between the
alt-right in the US the ultra
in Canada and weirdly the Philippines we
don't have an alt right right so these
are the disinformation networks that are
starting to work together I leave you
with what our world looks like 200 I
want to show you the impact on rattler I
forgot rattler is a startup right well
not so startup any more in 2012 so this
isn't fast sauce but I just want to show
you in 2012 this is how we began the red
is the spend we always spent more the
blue is the revenue right I always meant
to break even here in 2016 our year five
normal news groups break-even at least
five ten years five years later from
that right so a tech enabled news group
breaks even faster so we did April 2019
was our first month of positive net
income president detector was elected in
May even though we had positive net
income through the rest of the year the
attacks drove our revenue down so the
other thing that we learned as
advertisers will not be at the frontline
of defending right but even when our
revenues went down we continue to build
and then we slash the next year and
guess what in 2019 the year I have the
year I have eight charges and the years
I the year I got arrested we actually
made money crisis is opportunity right
and the flip side is that we diversified
our revenue stream because we were
forced to necessity is the mother of
invention and the things that were
investigative journalism driven the
things that we did as investigative
journalist to figure out the
disinformation networks are the very
things that allowed us to grow this
revenue stream I'll leave you with these
this is what our world is today Tim
Snyder said it here rip the heart out of
a democracy but this is the situation in
the Philippines combined with online and
offline violence to create a climate of
fear it is a climate of fear and we're
being lying you know and tell you this
but and
new questions a brutal drug war supports
those who fight for truth attack them
with the full force of the Philippine
government Lila de Lima has been in jail
for three years without a proper trial I
don't know what I am I think you know
someone actually told me I don't have to
be in prison right now because in a way
I already am in prison it depends it's
like a game of chicken how far do you go
you don't know and it took a mile to
actually tell me that all of the charges
I face can could if if I lose all of
them the maximum sentence is 83 years in
prison
you make them cautionary tales for
demanding the truth so what do we do
what do we do we start with the area of
influence you demand accountability for
how we continue to do that if each of us
does that we put our patch of ground
together stand up against bullies report
the lies demand accountability from your
American social media platforms those
are my two things that I demand an end
to impunity our government on the drug
war and Facebook tell your family and
friends courage spreads we begin by
taking care of what's in front of us I'm
going to leave you it isn't just rap ler
who's doing this it is every Filipino
journalist that journalists are under
attack globally and I'll leave you with
a minute and a half video that shows you
some of the things we have to deal with
we ever been harassed because of your
work yes have you been threatened online
I Oh have you been called bias yes have
you been called stupid yes many times by
idiots
have you been called disrespectful yes
have you been accused of corruption yes
have you been called ugly as a response
to any story yes have you been called
fake news oh yeah the same fake news
anything that's critical is fake right
have you been accused of being an
imperialist spy yes have you been
accused of being a communist operative
yes have you been accused of working for
the CIA yes have you been sexually
harassed as a journalist yes has your
family been threatened harassed or
alluded to yes
it has specifically my daughter when she
died there were a lot of people who made
fun of that have you been threatened
with the ring yes yes no not me but my
family have you been threatened with
violence yes have you been threatened
with death yes have you been told how
you're going to be killed yes as the
violence been described to you yeah blow
my head off or burn your life what will
stop you from reporting
nothing nothing nothing yes you have to
kill me we hold the line
[Applause]
okay
good evening my phone welcome everyone
I think we were all impressed we're
going I'm going to start off as a
moderator with just a couple of
questions and then we really would like
to hear from the guests especially the
students as they ask my good friend
Maria Ressa questions and I learned a
lot from there we had during my time in
the Philippines she wrote a book
Facebook to bin Laden ten days ten years
about terrorism and kidnapping of
abs-cbn a fun she worked with reporters
in southern Philippines and how they
worked to return I was so impressed by
the book but I invited her to my
residence to talk to my team about what
she needed to learn like many so
diplomats Ted and Paco we thought we
knew a lot well I realized that I did I
thought I knew a lot about the
Philippines until I married a Filipino
and I realized I did not know much and
that's the way it is in many in many
countries so my first question Maria is
why stay Wow the basic questions are the
hardest right I I think I have to stay
right I mean it it kind of is horrible
that we come of age at different times
and I'm now a senior journalist in the
Philippines and the baton was passed to
me at a time that's really horrific for
journalists but I think that I wouldn't
be me if I didn't fight it head-on
like it's easy to say you have standards
and ethics it's easy to say you believe
in the mission of journalism but if you
duck when it matters then you don't pen
that's I kind of played around with my
head you know like if because I did
think about it
I'm both an American and a Filipino
citizen my family is so adamant that I
you know so I asked my mom to leave the
Philippines and come back to the States
but the reality is that I don't think I
have a choice we have to you have to
hold the line because when you give it
up then you voluntarily give up your
rights
guys don't voluntarily give up your
rights Philippines for all of some
wandering beauty is a last decade been
the most dangerous country for
journalists and yet you are encouraging
young people to enter journals I hate
when he's asking questions right I used
to do this and it was more fun asking
him because I think you saw right our
information ecosystem creative
destruction it's already been destroyed
and so what we're doing in Rattler is
trying to deal with that destruction
journalists have lost our gatekeeping
powers we're no longer gatekeepers it
went to tak and tak has decided that
politicians can lie that's actually what
Mark Zuckerberg said right and so this
is the time when after the old world we
know has been destroyed you come in and
you create with the new world is going
to be that's incredible right and that's
part of the reason I stay and I work
every day I have never worked as I used
to think when I was in CNN I work really
hard at 24-hour news forget that
trappler is like every hour of every day
it's 150% of what you want but part of
it is because and I'll I'll toss this
back to you this is the time that
matters everything that we grew up with
everything that we knew is under attack
our democracy is under attack
when journalists are under attack
democracy is under attack and so I feel
like what we do matters and for the
young journalists here in this room when
you jump in now you're not gonna do what
I did when I started as a reporter which
is to follow what someone else has done
you'll actually be creating new things
and the better you understand data
technology and society behavioral
science the better your journalism will
be I would first like to give the
opportunity to two one new friend one
old friend Vicky Acevedo is here tonight
she was in the second class of women at
Yale went on a Harvard Law School has
had a distinguished career we're
welcoming her let me just first of all
say thank you very much for that
presentation I mean the big data issue
is so important
I just am wondering about the revelation
of truth i watch CNN or CMM VC or PBS
and they have consistently pointed out
the lies all the time
but it doesn't seem to make any
difference so I wonder if you could
address that I partially did and talking
about people who put their heads down
but why is it that revealing the lying
behavior doesn't change the citizens
behavior
so I think two reasons the first is you
know Daniel Kahneman's book thinking
fast thinking slow write our old world
was thinking slow journalists rational
thinking stood a chance in that world
because we valued it that was the kind
of
whoo those were the rules and the
systems we created the new world ruled
and enabled my tech is actually driven
by thinking fast right it's a thinking
fast world and I you you can't call them
anything but behavioral modification
systems social media platforms are
behavioral modification systems and we
are Bob loves dogs walking into it the
wrong behavior is rewarded right so mark
will say that it is about freedom of
speech it isn't about freedom of speech
because you can say anything you want
but not everything and especially when
it's violence not everything should have
wide distribution and in in the social
media platforms what actually gets
distributed faster and further are
incendiary comments lies laced with
anger and hate you know it it's part of
who we are so it's almost like the devil
and the angel on our shoulders right
except the devil keeps winning because
the the platform itself takes our
reactions and keeps us engaged engaged
I'm beginning to hate that word by
playing to the worst of human nature by
playing to the devil in us so part of
the tear gas power comes from the fact
that not only does he say those rich
people's because one of the narratives
they divided the division the first
division was between the rich and the
poor which is really huge in the
Philippines but what he did is he
promised the poor revenge different
thing right so it's the Thinking Fast
part is the part and that's part of the
reason I think that you know the design
this is built by design we are mildly
addicted you have elevated levels of
dopamine you have elevated levels of
oxytocin so that you stay and you share
that's so all of this must change but I
think part of it is because the tech
I had full rein right so for law if
there is no rule of law there is no
democracy also and that's part of the
problem because in the virtual world
there is no rule of law right and online
violence leads to real world violence we
know that also those those are clear so
that's part of the reason I think the
world is upside down is that makes sense
we got to fix the tap Maria thank you
for doing this you're such a good friend
and I am such a huge fan for your heroic
efforts and what you're doing for people
in freedom of speech and so when I think
about Ron and I were just the last World
Economic Forum at Davos and recently
also just with some friends and we were
talking about the debate of the
pressures on mark and Cheryl as they
think about it and at Davos we heard a
debate that the New York Times hosted
between regulation of big data and
self-regulation like how should we
really think about that so if you had
mark in front of you which I know you've
had opportunities to chat with him
directly from a self-regulation
perspective because I keep hearing from
friends the argument that it's a
lose-lose situation for him for him
because that if he regulated and became
the arbiter of what was lies or truth
that's not really the technology that he
built nor does he believe that that is
his role and so what for a
businessperson are the personal
responsibility given that you've studied
this so well like if you were talking to
him today what would be your advice to
him around what he could be actively
doing for self-regulation in the
technology because again I've heard the
argument because of the Conservatives
he'll say well they're gonna attack me
if I if I shut down all the lies they're
going up is it really about liberals and
conservatives so what would you what
would you say to mark so I think even
without doing anything the platforms are
already making choices but the way
they're making choices is they
rewarding lies they are rewarding the
manipulation right and this is
documented in the Muller report the the
networks of disinformation Russian this
information guys you were manipulated I
mean that's already a fact and the fact
that we don't know it's a fact that's
really scary because it will happen
again and it is happening again
that's first the second I think is so
the excuse that I don't want to regulate
speech you're already doing it because
you took the old rules you trash them
and you replace them with rules that are
not friendly to democracy journalists
spend all our lives learning how to make
boring facts interesting we learn how to
tell stories it's really hard to keep
your attention but now in the age of
social media someone will just lie and
lace it with anger and hate and we just
don't stand a chance in distribution
right so that's the second part what
solution I think there was this brief
period of time when they had free reign
and I think it was when instant articles
was brought in all the new scoops were
brought into Facebook Facebook in from
that time period by 2016
became the world's largest distributor
of news not coincidentally 2016 is when
the dominoes began to fall in May the
election of do tear tear a month later
was brexit Trump was November then you
go all the way to the Catalonia
elections that year because we found
BOTS that were working in both the US
and Catalonia elections tweeting
exclusively about the Philippines right
so we know this is happening I think it
takes leadership I think it's
enlightened self-interest because if
they don't change course an ambassador
would know this right whatever you do
you will be attacked but you have to do
the right thing so the question back to
him is what are your values you know
what are the values that govern this
it's almost like they created a city and
gave everyone a machine
and then said go at it right and Mad Max
wins that isn't the way society works
and it filters to reality because online
virtual world is reality
the Millennials here know that right so
that's I guess that's that's the reason
why I think it will take time a solution
I've been thinking about this and we
talked about this at lunch a little bit
is data portability a potential one
short-term solution because I don't want
to break up Facebook even though a lot
of the legislation is looking at
antitrust right I don't want to break
them up because they did have the
advantage but how do you help younger
groups like Jimmy Wales's new social
media platform what if we give Facebook
incentive to protect the users because
right now every incentive they have is
actually to continue going down this
path to the destruction of democracy
they tried to they spent more money
protecting our privacy they were
pummeled by the market they lost a lot
of money so what if a user like me if I
get attacked a lot I can take all the
data I created on the platform and
poured it over to Jimmy Wales this new
social media platform and I can take my
family and friends with me because I'll
do that they will protect us if they
will lose the network effect so I think
that's part of what we have to think
about but the reason why I don't think
self-regulation works is because they
had the chance and they didn't take it
so it goes back to what are the values I
think Tech is not it's not neutral at
any level
no matter back
thanks a lot Maria did you sure hi how
are you my name's Kyle you referred to
Facebook as a distribution platform and
so I was wondering if these lies and the
deceit and the manipulation that you
referred to I was wondering if this has
occurred on previous platforms in media
history did this happen when the
television came to be that this happened
in through radio and the printing press
and so forward and so forth and if so
how did we regulate it in the past so I
think we've never been at a stage where
the the rate of spread is exponential
this is truly game-changing right you're
talking just Facebook alone and you know
I have to say we're frenemies because
we're partners for Facebook I don't
sound like it do i I know the good it
can do which is part of the reason I get
disappointed when when it doesn't do the
good it can do so television this
printing press yes there's something
different with each one but it has never
been at the at the edge of a human's
ability to ingest right part of it is
it's like the difference between an
excel sheet and big data the difference
in scale creates a completely different
world right so when you're doing big
data you can see all these patterns you
won't be able to see in a small excel
sheet I think that the the tech
platforms have enabled so many good
things but at the same time they've also
enabled the rise of these populist
authoritarian leaders that are using
these same platforms to use information
operations against their own people to
change democracy and and this is a stat
in 2017 Freedom House came out with the
same well first study that said that in
at least 28 countries around the world
cheap armies on social media were
rolling back democracy last year Oxford
University's computational propaganda
Research Projects said that number is
now at least 70
country's right so what do we do well
what has happened in every industry tech
will say look this is a really difficult
industry to regulate is it any more
difficult than the airline industry or
finance or pharmaceuticals
we have regulated very complex
industries and you never allow some drug
maker to test the drug in public and say
let the user beware or let me get them
to say ok and then they can get poisoned
that's kind of what's happening right
the onus is on the user that you're
supposed to opt-out or opt-in it's not
about opting out or opting in it's about
knowing that when I get on a plane I
don't have to know how the plane works
to know I'll be safe in the plane that's
what governments are supposed to do
right
I didn't really answer your question
because I think we're at that face where
we're looking for the answer and I'll
connect it to one thing which is similar
to the end of world war 2 at the end of
World War 2 the atom bomb scared
everybody Hitler scared everyone and as
a global community we came together to
create Bretton Woods NATO the UN
Declaration of Human Rights that we
decided that we need to protect humanity
from the worst of what human beings do
we're at the same juncture today and
information is the problem now right but
we don't agree that an atom bomb went
off so the entire system has already
gone up in smoke but we don't even
realize it that's scary should there be
Christopher Wiley the Cambridge
analytical whistleblower said that in
his book he recommended there should be
building codes for tech platforms right
there should be ethical codes
Tristan Harris head of Humane tech he
was Google's ethicist at some point the
other thing Wiley said is every
individual coder should be legally
liable for
code that they create this is I'm just
saying this is a brave new world
no Altos right it's a brave new world
and we have the like grapple call a
spade a spade and demand protection as a
journalist the Philippines and the
United States we our Constitution is
patterned after the United States I'm
protected under the Constitution of both
of our countries and yet all of that
protection was stripped the minute I
entered the virtual world my name is Bob
and my question is this if we're going
to change course we're going to need new
narratives and my question is where do
these new narratives come from and maybe
what might be in them I wish Harry
Thomas would answer that question
the new directions I think you know the
one word that I don't hear a lot in tech
is values which is under which underpins
America it underpins every society that
pushes for progress right so I think the
first is you can see I'm very influenced
by social media because I grew Rattler
from zero to being the third top online
news website where the top digital only
website and I can see that the
incentives are all skewed because it
happened so fast
the rush to grow these platforms so tech
for me is something we cannot discount I
also don't think we should kill tech
cheela built a business on using tech
right Tech is does enable but when we
see something wrong for businessmen in
particular
there has to be some stop some
accountability so what what to do right
obviously our political systems have
already been affected
I came with something very simple which
is in your area of influence
please demand what you believe what
values you stand for what you believe
should happen make facts important
because everyone jumps to thinking fast
instead of thinking slow shares our
generation is the one that shares lies
seven times more than the Millennials
because we grew in a world of trust
right in a way these social media
platforms benefited from the trust
that's embedded in the way we build our
businesses and communities and now we're
going to have to rebuild that and
rethink it I'm sorry it's a fuzzy answer
maybe our esteemed ambassador do you
have an idea find a new leader no sorry
but I would say the truth justice value
still reign and they are so important we
cannot abdicate that under any
circumstances and we cannot become
transaction I think sorry you had a
question
it's karmic sir
my name is Stephen thank you for being
here I saw the documentary on cable very
impressive
for you my problem is this I've been
leading a not make that short I believe
in nonprofit for the last close to 10
years and I worked with Egyptian
students in Cairo when they have spring
occurred and I work with Ukrainian
students and I work with Syrian students
and the problem is they end up all
preaching to the choir
they don't reach out Ukraine has more
than done that more than the other two
but the Arab Spring failed in Egypt
because they were just talking to
themselves and my question to you is are
you reaching out to people who are not
in your camp because I happen to know a
few more than a few Filipinos in in New
York and they tell me they know about to
tear tear and they know just craziness
or whatever but they say you know what
he's done a lot for us he's yes he's
killed a lot of people but a lot of
those people are drunk with drug lords
or whatever so you know do I care about
Maria yeah Russell yes but the bottom
line is detached has done so much for us
that I'll just ignore it you know it
doesn't really matter to me I just want
the data to continue we have a much more
stable society you know that's like it
is here with Trump you know and his
appeal so my question to you is are you
really appealing to people who are not
of your ilk and if so let us know thank
you thanks for your question so number
one is that I never was of an ilk right
I mean I'm a report I'm a journalist and
I actually really did live with this
right the problem now is when I was
person when I was when my rights were
violated
I had first-hand knowledge of how the
government abused its powers and I
decided then to take a step forward into
something that's pretty uncharted for me
I talked about the injustice that I saw
I was unshackled and I hold government
account because my government
it's power right I'm not taking a sign I
never have I'm not a political animal
I'm a journalist and part of the you
know the Liberal Party and the
Philippines will say part of the reason
to tear they got elected is because
Rattler covered him and gave a
presidential debate we covered all five
camps equally and continue to do that
unfortunately we refused to stop doing
investigative reports and you can say oh
it feels really great it's okay to kill
a few people which are by the way
astroturf messages on social media which
is meant to change the way people think
right so that happens but at the same
time look this year foreign direct
investment is down 31 percent if you
look at the facts the facts say a
different thing but what happens when
facts don't matter take a look at the
Philippines
you know facts have to matter because in
the end we negotiate everything in a
public sphere and I need to listen I
by no means do I think I have any
solution I guess that's the best part of
being a reporter you want to get the
best knowledge from everyone else so you
can put the best thing together running
a company is similar to that that's the
kind of role I play in Rattler I try to
get the best ideas and we pull them
together that's what democracy should be
it isn't about one side yelling at
another right or saying this is better
than yours which by the way came from
inciting a mob in the public sphere this
is information warfare so I go back to
that yes I do
number two we reach out all the time
many of the propagandists in that
network that I showed you actually
worked we're part of our civic
engagement team and it is so painful to
see some of these tactics than being
used before this time as a reporter as a
journalist I've never used good versus
evil in the
I do now and I think the advice I get I
gave last night to some Yale students is
that the values are so important now I
think while you're still in school
define that line we're on this side
you're good and on this side you're evil
because the world is complex and it it
literally manipulates you so be clear
who you are what are the values you
stand for and I think that's the best
thing so my quick response is I continue
trying to reach out but when I am
vilified and portrayed exponentially as
a tax evader even though my company was
given a tax the top corporate tax award
six months before they filed five tax
evasion cases against us I get angry so
I learn anger management hi my name is
Sarah I'm a second year student at the
law school here so it appears that your
seem to be more in favor of stricter
regulation within big tech and social
media platforms so what is your opinion
on stricter media laws so for example
for demonstrable false information ie
fake news do you think that should be
criminalized you know one of the things
we're fighting against in the
Philippines is that libel is a criminal
offense right the cyber libel means that
the penalty is double normal libel and I
face criminal charges
so we've long been against criminalizing
libel and I don't think that so here's
another complexity to add to the layer
our old world was complex enough right
when you add the layer of tech look at a
country like Singapore right Singapore
is about 5 million people Harry can talk
more about this but Singapore has
10-year plans and they're actually very
efficient it's a democracy not in the
way we are they passed the first fake
noose law maybe second Malaysia was
first in in Southeast Asia and now it's
being used against folks who
are perceived to be critical of
government there isn't a
one-size-fits-all answer and there
certainly isn't a quid pro quo if we
regulate tax should we regulate media we
regulate media should we not regulate
there isn't anything like that these are
false equivalencies I think for me all
I'm trying to do is to go back to how do
we protect the public sphere how do we
take the new technology machine learning
artificial intelligence these platforms
know you more intimately than your most
intimate relationships because you put
that data in there it's not content its
behavior right so I'm trying to
understand the world and trying to stay
out of jail
hi I'm Greg I'm a student here from
Indonesia and I know that you were in
Jakarta during the democratic transition
between Suharto and the reform period
and in Manila before that so having seen
and reported on a lot of authoritarians
how is it different now or is it just
the same I I started my career in 1986
34 years ago with People Power and then
I was very privileged with CNN they gave
me a front row seat right when I felt
like oh my gosh these changes from
authoritarian one man rulers Singapore
Lee Kuan Yew to go chop Tom maja tear
stepping down and now of course he was
back and now he stepped out again and
then Indonesia the end of almost 32
years of Suharto
was incredible and I I was I felt like
the pendulum like a pendulum was
released and it was swinging back and I
think the the painful part for me last
three years ago was to see that pendulum
go back and it went back because of the
information ecosystem right so Indonesia
has the same has similar problems the
top Twitter city in the world
Jakarta and let's look back to the days
of Suharto when the violence and Ambon
in 1999 10,000 people were killed
because one newspaper printed something
that was incendiary grenade was thrown
in a mosque right and but the killers do
you remember this was before you were
born
yes but but so I remember then how
difficult that was right and that was
only a newspaper and then we saw the
riots there was the Jakarta riots again
recently and Indonesia actually had to a
hawk the those were sorry you know this
better than I do that I s Nick the
communal violence there was the time I
was in Jakarta I covered I went through
all 27 at that point provinces and I
think I covered every single form of
conflict in a town from ethnic violence
from the dye acts and the matarese the
beheadings that happened there this was
in 1997 from Aceh separatism violence
it's a tinderbox and I worry about
social media right so sorry I guess I
ran off into where I wanted to go I
worry about the information ecosystem I
think that when you manipulate us
emotionally
we have no defenses against it and when
it is done for power we cannot hold our
governments to account right sorry just
a quick follow-up your walk down thank
you again thank you but your walk oh I'm
Ron I'm Sheila something and your walk
down memory lane made me think of a term
puppet government which I thought the
general public of most of those nations
that were under puppet governments
recognized the the influence of money
behind
the leaders and and again the general
public so the majority of the people and
now in this age you know my question
really is about you know that term in my
opinion doesn't seem to be used anymore
because it seems that this big money has
somehow and new systems gotten somehow
to a tipping point as an example where
it's sort of mass the influence of big
money to command sort of what we're
seeing in policy and the outcomes could
you comment a little about how to make
that big money more transparent today
that again you know I would say the
majority people would say that's not a
good thing to have big money influencing
us in this way through these funded
campaigns so so for example the Marcoses
are still billionaires some people in
this room might not know that but that
is still a fact yeah I CIJ are you guys
familiar with AI CIJ International
Center for Investigative Journalism
there's huge data that has been released
globally and journalists in many
different parts of the world come
together to work on this data some of
that data exposes the markers wealth the
Panama papers if you're familiar with
that that came from I CI J's
collaborative work what you really made
me think of and I guess I went off on an
aside from your question was the
geopolitical power because beyond the
corporation's is actually the money that
and I see this in the Philippines the
money that's flowing in the Philippines
that is helping change geopolitical
power China Russia United States the
Philippines is pivotal always has been
right and in October 2016 when President
detect I went to Beijing on a state
visit and he didn't tell his his foreign
affairs secretary that he he announced
that the Philippines would move away
from the United States
pivot to China and Russia that was the
first time I heard Russia in Beijing
right so that money has come in badly we
know this and we're trying to track that
morale we that we build
of murali in the Philippines its Chinese
right supposedly but the rebuilding
hasn't happened okay that's that was so
I'm just saying that the money is a
money flow of governments for political
geopolitical power and that and then
you're talking about the kind of money
that families would have right what
we're seeing right now in the
Philippines is the building of a new
kleptocracy and you're seeing it in
plain sight because it's two years
before the end of President do Tartus
term he has won six year term and
they're now getting ready for elections
next campaigns will begin next year so
what's happening is the blue chip
companies the largest conglomerate in
the Philippines
dianna group has been forced to
essentially sell its shares to
businessmen chosen who are friendly to
president doTERRA to the kleptocracy is
happening in plain sight how do you
should say you should talk more that's
so yes the flow of money is important
can it be more transparent yes has it
ever been transparent in the Philippines
never which is why investigative
journalism is also important we're
trying to do more but it's scary for me
that you have the Lopez Group a
conglomerate the Yala group the first
specific group Manny Pauline and these
are three big conglomerates who are
being forced like the Philippine Daily
Inquirer to ship to sell their shares to
change for money to change hands because
again a kleptocracy is being built we're
not the first country where there's a
kleptocracy so all these words oligarchs
you know the names change but thus the
system remains the same
hello Marianne I am a senior from the
Philippines and her father what is one
of the investors of Rattler sorry didn't
need I was wondering so it seems like
the world that we're living in
well the Philippines Marcos Marcos Ian
kind of like media censorship is seems
to be rearing its ugly head once again
like you've had all of these lawsuits
and arrest warrants against you I think
just last week the National Police
brought up that Presidential Decree
number 90 under Marcos which is about
like rumor mongering which was you know
isn't is defunct but you know they're
kind of returning to that and this whole
thing with abs-cbn one of the major
national networks on the verge of being
closed down so I was just wondering how
you are navigating that kind of tricky
space it's like a game of chicken you
just keep going down the right path
because they can make so my lawyers I
asked my lawyer says right before we
came here I was on with my lawyer site
so I asked my lawyers this what can they
do they can do anything that's really
the reality I could be charged with
child abuse right and I guess though my
best defense my only defense is to shine
the light to tell you the story to tell
you what's happening I think the reason
why rattler is still alive is because
one were owned largely by journalists we
decided that we would hold the line and
then - we asked international news
groups to tell our story and it
reverberates because it's happening in
many countries around the world so I
guess part of it is you know they always
say don't sweat the small stuff it's now
the small stuff is so big it's like oh I
could go to jail I won't think about it
I'll just focus on where I need to go
and that works for now that's why I'm
also hoping our
the tech allies now frenemies remember I
keep appealing time I work very closely
with with the tech companies because
they're really critical for the first
step because if our what the civic
engagement looked like in the age of
social media right for your group so I I
guess that's a long-winded answer
I think the short and is we look at
people like you we are developing the
next generation of journalists this time
requires far more courage than at any
other time and you at Yale are so
privileged and powerful and please like
the thinking slow world I so long for
that because we can't move forward
without that
my name is Jo Jo batad I'm a
filipino-american I'm an officer of the
Association here so I'm part of the
community and I'm also part of the
battleground because as part of the
community I know what the gentleman here
told or set up a while ago there are so
many prepared a Filipino Americans as
well and it feels to me like it was even
harder now I was also a anti Marcus
activist in my years in the University
of the Philippines it was even easier
then than it is now
I can easily reason with pro Marcos
supporters before in the 80s than to do
it with throw the 30 supporters now and
many of them are make former colleagues
in the left okay so we were split so and
we are coming to 2022 right that's the
presidential elections we were clobbered
in the in social media so it was very
hard to to do the debates or to win and
debates what is your outlook of 2022 in
terms of the battlefield that means the
information battlefield because we will
be in there again we will be debating
with our friends who aren't with the
other camp and we were clobbered because
they were so organized and we were like
we were coming from different places how
are we gonna win this if you have any
ideas for people like us who are in the
community I think it's impossible to win
the social media war unless you don't
you have no values I mean you know the
only way to win this is it's a scorched
earth policy right the it's the use of
anger and hate to spread and you
demonize someone
it's a world that I don't believe in
which is why when Mark Zuckerberg says
we don't want to be the arbiters of
truth you already are they're
prioritizing speech that incites the
hate and violence more than they
prioritize facts right this is built
into the system so I think the first
thing is I've called it a behavioural
modification system but think about it
like this in this system that they've
created they decided that they wanted to
grow it fast so fast
there's a cost to growing it fast so a
tech person made the decision that
they're going to use friends of friends
because if it's friends of friends just
that one decision you'll be able to
close triangles it's it's called there's
a paper by Peter Granovetter called the
strength of weak ties and so they close
these triangles but in doing that they
build polarization into that system
because friends are friends
so think about like this if you have
rightist tendencies let's just like in
our world maybe it was like this in the
Philippines it was like this in the u.s.
you had Fox and CNN so you were you were
farm you had your own media things but
in the Philippines we were like this so
if if I had rightist tendencies and I
only talked to my friends and grew my
network of friends then I move further
here and then if I had left his
tendencies and I only talked to all my
friends and grew my own network of
friends I move further here you never
see the other side Eli Pariser wrote a
book about the filter bubbles right this
is in the design so how do we do that
it's not about conversation or even
listening to each other or convincing
each other in order to convince someone
you have to listen to each other that's
not built into the design so so I'm
saying I've seen good people use the
exact same black strategy as the doTERRA
tech camp and you know what it leaves a
trail and and we can see that I don't
think that's the right way to go either
right that's part of the reason I think
we need to demand
and that the platform's changed the way
they create a system because they talk
about a market of ideas a market has
rules you check out here you don't bring
a gun in right you have to have rules
for a marketplace of ideas because right
now you can't insure the election that
election integrity even exists
we can't because the information
ecosystem is so flawed thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]